we know how great it went for John
McCain to select Sarah Palin to be his
vice presidential running mate in 2008.
so naturally the next step is for Trump
to choose Marjorie Taylor Green in 2024
right and indeed it has been suspected
that she wants the job
it has now been confirmed that Marjorie
Taylor green does indeed want that job
we suspected that the lunatic extremist
conspiracy theorist Marjorie Taylor
green was desperate to be Donald Trump's
vice presidential running mate now we
know it and this is the continued Jerry
springerification of the Republican
Party
Marjorie Taylor Green's dangerous
conspiracy theories and horrible
statements obviously have no place in
the White House they have no place
within a heartbeat of the presidency but
when it is the modern Republican party I
don't assume that it's out of the
question NBC news reports Marjorie
Taylor green aims to be Trump's VP pick
in 2024. former Trump hate Steve Bannon
has spoken with green and says quote she
sees herself on the short list for
Trump's VP now whether she is on Trump's
shortlist is a completely separate
question two people who have spoken to
Green say that she is trying to be the
VP this is no shrinking violet she's
ambitious she's not shy about that nor
should she be said Steve Bannon she sees
herself on the short list for Trump's VP
paraphrasing cookie Roberts when
Marjorie Taylor green looks in the
mirror she sees a potential president
smiling back a Second Source who has
been advising green said quote her whole
vision is to be vice president the
source is tied to Trump and spoke on the
condition of anonymity said he also
believes green would be on Trump's
shortlist the goal is at the heart of
Green's recent effort to Rebrand herself
as a politician who can stand to stride
The Divide between the party's hideliner
hardliners and its establishment Wing so
understand that this sheds major life
unto why Marjorie Taylor green after
saying for years she is not part of the
Republican establishment it explains why
she criticized those who descended from
supporting Kevin McCarthy for speaker
just weeks ago and joined those who
support Kevin McCarthy she sees an
opportunity and you know what Marjorie
Taylor green is out of her mind but
she's not
stupid
in the sense that she recognizes now
that Republicans are going to control
now that the Republicans do control the
house she can be on one side or the
other she can be one of the detractors
of Republicans within the house or she
can be on the side of we are now in
power we are legitimate people to be
taken seriously rather than the clowns
that many correctly see us to be and so
she has decided to put herself on the
side of the speakership and of the
establishment Republican Party
clearly this was all to try to make
herself more palatable and to be taken
more seriously
to potentially be Donald Trump's running
mate now she is out of her mind she said
the 2018 California wildfires maybe
there was a Jewish space laser that was
a factor she has alluded to the 9 11
attacks being a false flag event in the
sense that she said she's not really
sure that a plane did hit the Pentagon
she has talked about shootings
potentially being hoaxes or hoax-like
she of course is one of the biggest
promulgators of the obvious to any sane
person lie that the 2020 election was
not really won by Joe Biden but rather
stolen by Biden and actually won by
Trump this is what we might refer to as
a dumpster fire of an elected official
and not only does she want to be Trump's
VP there are people who would vote for
her to be the vice president that's
maybe the most frightening thing now
admittedly it may be a relatively small
portion of the Republican party I don't
know we're going to find out I am sure
that she is being vetted among with
others to potentially be potentially be
Trump's VP but thinking ahead many steps
Trump as president was humiliating
enough for the United States okay
if somehow Marjorie Taylor green became
the vice president it would be even more
embarrassing let's hope it doesn't
happen because it would also endanger
our national security in all sorts of
different ways but Marjorie Taylor green
we knew it and it's now been confirmed
she wants to be Trump's VP we'll have
more on all of these stories on our
Instagram find us on Instagram by
searching davidpackman show find me on
Instagram at david.pakman
one of our sponsors is curiositystream
the best place to find and watch
documentaries on politics history
science technology nature you name it
they have it curiosity stream has a
deeper collection of documentaries than
any other streaming service they add new
titles every week including exclusive
award-winning films and shows you can't
watch anywhere else I just watched
ancient engineering
fascinating insights into how stuff was
built before modern technology and the
Industrial Revolution you can watch
curiosity stream on all of your devices
phone desktop game console Smart TV I'm
always finding great documentaries on
curiosity stream that I can't find on
any other platforms it's really the only
place to go for documentaries and they
have a special deal for my audience you
can get curiosity stream for 25 off just
go to curiositystream.com Pacman and use
the code Pacman and the link is down
below